Voiceover:These are
vectors A and B, all right?
That's vector A, that's vector B.
Which of the following describes a valid
way of obtaining vector A minus vector B?
So let's look at our
choices right over here.
Here they just depicted
vector B, just like it's
depicted here, it's maybe
shifted over a little bit.
And then over here,
they depicted vector A,
the negative of vector
A, and it looks like
they're taking the negative of vector A,
and to that they're adding
vector B, and then they're
claiming that this magenta
vector is A minus B.
If we ignore what they
wrote over here, what
they've done is they've
added negative A to B.
So this is the negative
of vector A plus vector B.
Or we could think of it as
vector B minus vector A.
So this one right over here is not right.
If we swap the signs,
if this was a negative,
if we put negative A plus
B, then we'd say okay,
this is accurate, but
they want us to figure out
valid ways of obtaining A
minus B and this isn't that.
This is B minus A.
Let's look at the other choice.
You have vector A.
Let's start at the tail of vector A,
get to the head of vector A.
Over here we have the tail
of the negative of vector B,
so they essentially flipped
it over when you take the
negative of it, and so we're
adding negative B to A.
If we take the tail of
where we started to the head
of where we ended, yes,
this would be vector A
plus negative vector B,
which is the same thing
as vector A minus vector
B, so that one is right.
That's a valid way of obtaining
vector A minus vector B.